[Applaudissements]
les amendes variant et suivez moi je
vais essayer de me frayer un chemin
jusqu'aux bureaux du candidat mais alors
vraiment c'est pas simple quand vous
pouvez les voir s'il ya une foule
incommensurable regardé la foule
c'est dingue c'est un vrai succès cette
foule incroyable qui se pressent calmez
vous monsieur ça ne mène nulle part en
plus pas mal à l'épaule mais je vais
prendre le prochain c'est complet je
prends le prochain et nous voici en
direct du qg de campagne de jean luc
bennahmias et là encore l'effervescence
auprès de tous les soutiens et du
candidat la foule se presse
[Applaudissements]